양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum의 기술
교육 디렉터예요. 이번 강의는 이 시리즈의 여덟 번째 강의이고, 양자 알고리즘을 다루는
시리즈 두 번째 유닛의 마지막 강의예요. 우리는 계산의 쿼리 모델에 대해 이야기했는데, 여기에는 양자
알고리즘이 포함돼요. 이 모델에서 고전 알고리즘보다 증명 가능한 이점을 제공하는 알고리즘이죠. 그와 관련된 기본 개념들과
양자 알고리즘, 그리고 계산 비용을 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지에 대해서도 논의했어요. 이전 강의에서는 위상 추정과 Shor의
알고리즘에 대해 다뤘어요. 이번 강의에서는 Grover의 알고리즘을 논의할 거예요. 이 알고리즘은 양자가 고전보다
이차적 이점을 제공해요. 소위 비구조적 탐색 문제에서요. 강의에 들어가면
설명해 드릴게요. 이것들은 모두 양자 알고리즘에 관한 기본 주제예요. 다른 양자
알고리즘들도 있고, 서로 다른 양자 알고리즘과 양자 알고리즘 기법들을 연결하는 일반적인 패러다임들도 있어요.
관심 있으신 분들은 알려진 양자 알고리즘을 분류하고 많은 참고 문헌을 포함하는 양자 알고리즘 동물원을 확인해 보세요.
개발에 기여한 원본 연구 논문들도 포함돼 있어요. 하지만 이 시리즈에서는
기본기에만 집중할 거예요. 다음 강의부터는 새로운 주제로 넘어갈 거예요. 하지만
먼저 Grover의 알고리즘에 대해 이야기해 봐요. 강의 개요는 이렇습니다. 먼저
다룰 계산 문제에 대한 짧은 논의로 시작할 거예요. 그게 바로 비구조적 탐색이에요. 직관적으로 말하면,
비구조적 탐색 문제는 정렬되지 않았고 유용한 방식으로 정리되지 않은 항목들의 모음을 검색하는 것으로
생각할 수 있어요. 그다음에는 Grover의 알고리즘을 다룰 건데, 이건 고전 알고리즘보다 이차적 이점을 제공하는 양자 알고리즘이에요.
그게 정확히 무슨 의미인지는 곧 설명할게요. 이 알고리즘이 어떻게 작동하는지 매우 높은 수준에서 설명하면,
먼저 초기화 단계가 있고, 그다음에 제가 Grover
연산이라고 부를 작업이 일정 횟수 반복돼요. 마지막으로 측정이 이루어지면서 탐색 문제의 후보
해가 드러나요. Grover 연산이 무엇인지, 그리고 그것이 어떻게
양자 컴퓨터에서 구현될 수 있는지 설명할 거예요. 그다음 이 연산이 무엇을 하는지, 왜 탐색에 유용한지
더 잘 이해하기 위한 분석을 할 거예요. 강의 세 번째 부분은 반복 횟수에 관한 거예요.
Grover의 알고리즘에서, 다시 말해 Grover 연산을 몇 번 적용해야 하는지에 관한 거죠. 알고리즘이
찾고자 하는 것을 찾는 데 성공할 가능성을 최대화하면서 동시에 비용을 최소화하고 싶다는 전제하에요.
탐색 문제에 정확히 하나의 해가 있는 특수한 경우인 유일 탐색 문제부터 시작할 거예요.
그다음에는 여러 해가 있을 때 어떻게 되는지 고려해 볼게요. 마지막으로
Grover의 알고리즘과 그 일반화에 대한 몇 가지 간략한 언급으로 강의를 마무리할게요. 이제
강의 전반에 걸쳐 다룰 계산 문제부터 시작해 봐요. 먼저, 우리가 자주 하듯이,
Sigma는 이진 알파벳을 나타낸다고 할게요. 이 강의 전반에 걸쳐 이 표기법을 사용할 거니까 계속
상기시켜 드리지 않을게요. 길이 n의 이진 문자열을 이진 알파벳으로 매핑하는 함수 f가 있다고 해봐요.
우리의 가정은 이 함수를 쉽게 평가할 수 있다는 거예요.
예를 들어 이 함수를 위한 불리언 circuit이 있고 그 크기가 n에 대해 다항식이라고 해봐요. 이것이
반드시 어떤 의미에서든 간단한 함수라는 뜻은 아니에요. 또는 이 함수를 특별히 잘 이해한다는 의미도 아니에요. 예를 들어
F를 계산하기 위한 꽤 복잡하고 지저분한 불리언 circuit이 있을 수 있어요. 다양한 입력 문자열에서 평가는 가능하지만 반드시
우리 삶을 편하게 해주도록 설계된 멋진 형태는 아닌 거죠. 우리의 목표는
해를 찾는 거예요. 여기서 해란 F가 1로 평가되게 하는 길이 n의 이진 문자열이에요. 일반적으로 이건 매우 어려운
계산 문제예요. 적어도 매우 어렵다고 의심되죠. 특히 입력이 실제로
함수 f를 계산하기 위한 불리언 circuit의 설명이라면, 이건 소위 NP 완전 문제예요. 이 문제를
형식화하는 한 가지 방법은 쿼리 문제로 보는 거예요. 실제로 이 강의의 목적상 이 문제를
쿼리 모델의 맥락에서만 생각하는 게 합리적이에요. 하지만 이 문제가 실제로 어디서, 언제
발생할 수 있는지 생각해보면, f가 불리언
circuit으로 계산된다고 생각하는 게 더 자연스러워요. 강의 6에서 봤듯이, 불리언 circuit을 가져와서
쿼리 연산 또는 쿼리 gate를 구현하기 위한 양자 circuit으로 변환하는 구성을 통해 이 두 관점을 연결할 수 있어요. 어쨌든 개념적으로 말해서
이 문제의 입력은 함수 f이고, 우리는 해가 있으면 찾고 있어요.
만약 해가 없다면, 즉 F가 상수 0 함수로 판명된다면, 올바른 출력은
해가 없다고 보고하는 거예요. 이게 비구조적 탐색 문제예요.
F에 대해 해를 찾기 쉽게 만드는 특별한 게 없다는 의미에서요. 이미
정렬된 데이터나 탐색을 용이하게 하는 어떤 데이터 구조에 로드된 데이터를 검색하는 게 아니에요. 그리고
도움이 될 수 있는 함수 f에 대한 어떤 약속도 없어요. 한 가지 생각해보면,
전화번호부에서 특정 전화번호를 찾는 것 같아요. 이름을 찾는 것과 반대로요. 이름 찾기는 훨씬 쉬운데,
이름들이 알파벳 순으로 정렬되어 있다고 가정하면요. 실용적으로 말하면, 검색을 쉽게 하는 방식으로
정리하고 저장하는 데이터를 검색하는 것에 관한 게 사실 아니에요. 오히려 복잡한 방정식의
해를 찾거나, 예를 들어 자물쇠를 여는 비밀번호를 찾는 것에 더 가까워요.
참고로, 그 모델의 실용적 관련성에 대해 어떻게 생각하든 상관없이 쿼리 모델의 맥락에서 이 문제를 생각하는 게 합리적이에요.
물론 실제 생활에서는 오라클이나 블랙박스가 없어요. 하지만 달리 알게 될 때까지는
복잡하고 신비로운 불리언 circuit이 일종의 블랙
박스 같아요. 이제 이 비구조적 탐색 문제를 해결하기 위한 알고리즘에 대해 생각해 봐요.
단순함을 위해 쿼리 모델에서 이걸 할 거예요. 함수에 대한 블랙박스가 아닌 불리언 circuit이 있다면
여전히 쿼리 알고리즘을 실행할 수 있어요. 하지만 물론 쿼리를 기반으로 하지 않는 새로운 알고리즘이
이 문제에 대해 발견될 가능성을 배제할 수는 없어요. 하지만 그
가능성에 대해서는 걱정하지 않을 거예요. 먼저 약간의 표기법이 있어요. 함수 f의 총 입력 문자열 수는 2의